die sogar doppelte präsenz autos auf
einer tagung zum deutschen idealismus zu
deren einladung ich noch mal sehr
herzlich danke mag manchen etwas
verwundert haben der zu diesem thema
eher namen wie emanuel hirsch oder
andere in die intensive rezipienten von
fichte hegel und co vermutet abgesehen
von der wichtigen linie kann fries die
zu der wir jetzt entscheiden und es
gehört haben und die glaube ich auch der
entscheidende punkt zu diesem thema war
otto ist sucht man abhandlungen
eigentliche abhandlungen zu den großen
erz aposteln des deutschen idealismus
bei otto bekanntlich vergeblich vielmehr
hängt ihm sogar das klischee an ein für
die großen spekulativen system
philosophien und musikalischer
sentimentaler mystiker und
psychologisierende religionsgeschichte
mit zuweilen esoterischen tendenzen oder
noch schlimmer ein
religionswissenschaftler zu sein
das haben sich übrigens nicht nur
bösartige gegner ausgedacht sondern auch
otto selbst gefiel es hin und wieder
sich als zum beispiel modernistisch
pietistisch angehauchter lutheraner mit
gewissen quäker neigungen zu bezeichnen
und auch in seinen werken hat otto dem
gerücht er stehe dem idealismus eher
fern tüchtig nahrung gegeben besonders
in seiner oft wiederholten scharfen
polemik gegen jene schulen strömungen
und denkt traditionen die er als
rationalismus oder als rationalisten
bezeichnet gemeint ist damit keineswegs
der klassische rationalismus des 16 bis
18 jahrhunderts sondern ein bisschen die
anfänge der geistesgeschichte
zurückreichende vernunft und
spekulations optimistische haltung der
otto insbesondere in
religionsangelegenheiten unterstellt zu
stark und allzu schnell der ethik der
metaphysik oder der empirisch
systematischen wissenschaft im
aristotelischen fluchtpunkt zuzuneigen
und dabei dabei die ganz eigene provinz
des spirituellen dosen wie es bei ihm da
heißt in der religionsgeschichte zu
unterschätzen
schleiermacher für ihn natürlich der
entscheidende anker
gewesen bildungs geschichtlich das auto
in diesem rationalismus vorwurf auch vor
den großen protagonisten des deutschen
idealismus nicht halt macht zeigt
beispielsweise seine deutung von
johannes 424 in seinem hauptwerk das
heilige auto schreibt hier
es sei das berühmte pneu matthäus also
gott ist geist eben jene bibelstelle auf
die sich zitat die rationalisten mit
vorliebe zu berufen pflegen und er meint
damit ausdrücklich hegel um dieses
wortes willen fährt er fort also dieses
wortes gottes geist hielt hegel das
christentums christentum für die höchste
weil für die wahrhaft geistige religion
in der gott als geist das heißt für ihn
als die absolute vernunft selbst erkannt
und verkündet werde
man mag das hegel philologisch
vielleicht unpräzise finden worum es
otto hier aber geht ist denke ich
deutlich er moniert eine einseitig
philosophische vernunft zentrierte
deutung des geist begriffs was johannes
und mit ihm die dunklen quellen der
religionsgeschichte eigentlich im sinn
hatten ist vertont nämlich folgendes
zitat wenn johannes von geist redet so
denkt er nicht an absolute vernunft
sondern an das prima das heißt an das
was aller welt allem fleisch ganz
entgegengesetzt ist ein himmelswesen und
wunder wesen schlechthin an das ganz
rätsel und geheimnisvolle das überall im
verstand aller vernunft des natürlichen
menschen ist er denkt an dem geist der
da weht wo er will
gehörst sein sausen aber du weißt nicht
von wanne näher kommt und wohin erfährt
gerade diese scheinbar ganz irrationale
aussage weist am stärksten hinauf das
irrationale in der biblischen gottes
idee
es geht also um die ruhe nicht um den
weltgeist otto will zu fassen bekommen
was zitat lebendiges nun sei anstelle
eines touristisch korrekten aber toten
gottesbegriff was erfahren sei anstelle
nationalistischer beweis künste was
ergebung dem unabhängigkeits gefühl und
andacht sein anstelle wichtiger hoch
schwinge was erlösung bedürftigkeit sei
anstelle moralis tischer selbst
vervollkommnung ohne für die ablation
minister ohne füllung für die ablation
omen ist in den biblischen ideen können
so otto
die tiefsten mysterien der religion für
rationalisten und für moralisten
mythologische fossile sein
hier scheint mir der springende punkt zu
liegen die grundlegende these einer
kategorie religiöser intuition mit der
religion mit sich selber anfängt wie
otto immer wieder betont und ohne deren
bejagung man das buch über das heilige
wieder autor eingangs bemerkt erst gar
nicht weiter zu lesen braucht erweckt
den eindruck zwischen autos zu dunklen
material neigender frömmigkeit
theoretischer religionskunde und dem
idealistischen denken läge ein tiefer
graben wie an jedem gerücht ist auch
hier mit sicherheit wahres dran und
dennoch liegen die dinge bei genauerem
hinsehen so einfach nicht die vorbehalte
die otto gegenüber dem idealismus und
seiner geistesgeschichtlichen tradition
entgegenbrachte gehen durch auf eine
sehr ernsthafte hre sehr viel
ernsthafter auseinandersetzung mit
serbien zurück wie wir eben ja auch
schon ausführlich gehört haben
das lässt schon so eine ganz frühe
edition von schleiermacher reden
deutlich erkennen hier kommt besonders
fichte immer wieder zur sprache
meine vermutung ist dass kritik und
würdigung des idealismus bei otto
gewissermaßen in einander liegen und
dabei auf subtile weise mit dem
herzstück seiner theologie verbunden
sind
diesen sicherlich recht ungeschützten
gedanken folgend möchte ich nun ottos
idealismus rezeption
ausschnitten etwas nachspüren und lasse
dann natürlich die friesische linie ganz
bewusst aus das ist keine ganz einfache
aufgabe denn die schmalen linien liegen
in seinem werk sehr weit verstreut
es kann also nicht um fichte hegel und
schelling zitate gehen sondern er geht
es wie mir scheint um den weiteren
kontext und um einen dahinter stehen das
ganz grundsätzliches problem bei otto
nämlich um die frage nach sinn und
bedeutung des spekulativen in theologie
und religion im durchgang durch autos
werke wähle ich der einfachheit halber
drei anlaufpunkte erstens und da hoffe
ich jetzt nicht allzuviel redundanzen zu
erzeugen die eben schon vier erwähnten
naturalismus debatte zwei autos
hauptwerk das heilige das wie angedeutet
maßgeblich zu dem eindruck von ottos
irrational anti idealistischer
schlagseite beigetragen hat und möchte
drittens auf das dickste buch autos zu
sprechen kommen in dem gerade das
rationale und gerade das spekulative und
damit auch in gewisser weise das erbe
des idealismus im mittelpunkt steht
nämlich das buch west-östliche mystic
von 1926 in den genannten werken scheint
mir wie in ottos denken überhaupt
besonders der eindruck goethes eine
gewisse schlüsselrolle zu spielen
daher wird der letzte teil und ausblick
meines referats ganz kurz ottos
eigenartiger goethe rezeption gelten in
der ich auch eine pointe seiner haltung
gegenüber einem idealistischen und
spekulativen vermutet
ich komme zum ersten punkt die frühe
spur von autos auseinandersetzungen mit
dem umfeld des deutschen idealismus
führt wir haben es eben schon gehört zu
seinem ersten großen forschungsprojekt
nach der luther dissertation und den
studie zum schleiermacher die rede ist
von der jahrelangen beschäftigung mit
naturalismus und religion die in dem
buch naturalistische welten und
religiöse weltansicht ihren
monografischen höhepunkt gefunden hat
das anliegen des überaus komplexen und
damals sehr viel beachteten buches ist
gegenüber der seinerzeit verbreiteten
bewegung eines naturalistischen moniz
muss im umfeld von bestsellern wie ernst
haeckels welt rätseln oder büchern das
kraft und stoff die möglichkeit einer
wie otto es nennt frommen weltanschauung
offen zu halten
das grundproblem an dem verbreiteten
naturalistischen vulgär darwinismus
seinerzeit sieht otto besonders darin
dass hier naturwissenschaftliche
erkenntnisse zur weltanschauung und zur
philosophischen weltdeutung erhoben
werden was er den misston dabei
besonders übel nimmt es deren berufung
auf goethe dessen naturkundliche studien
zur morphologie in so otto gewaltsamen
streichen dazu genutzt werden die
naturalistischen für die zeitungs
ideologien in dichterische weihen zu
kleiden auto tut man alles dafür
goethe aus dieser naturalistischen
klammer zu befreien und ihn stattdessen
zum protagonisten einer gegen lehre zu
machen die ihr unter dem stichwort der
theologie zusammenfasst auto hält die
idee der zitat abhängigkeit des
seelischen vom körperlichen für
grundsätzlich falsch und begibt sich
damit ganz auf jene linie der
naturphilosophie die im idealismus des
neunzehnten jahrhunderts ihren höhepunkt
gefunden hat inbegriffen wie intel heißt
sind geschichte und unbedingtem sieht er
dimensionen der wirklichkeit den
gegenüber natur denen gegenüber
naturwissenschaftliche forschung nur ein
schmales derivat darstellt rückblickend
schreibt otto später es sei ihm darum
gegangen gegen den auf blinde
naturkräfte bauen den rationalismus der
darwinisten
für zitat die ratio in der welt für die
möglichkeit rational theologischer
weltanschauung und damit für klassische
idealistisches projekt einzutreten
doch dabei bleibt es nicht was ihn
eigentlich und darüber hinausgehend
interessiert sind die ursprünglichen
gründe jena frommen weltanschauung im
religiösen bewusstsein
foto steht fest jetzt kommt ein längeres
zitat dass frömmigkeit und fromme
weltansicht niemals durch das
theologisch spekulative denken in die
welt gekommen sind sondern immer schon
da waren
bevor man solche erwägungen anstellte
lange vor ihnen entsprangen sie aus
anderen quellen
diese quellen liegen tief im gemüt und
geschichte ihnen nachzudenken ihren ort
aufzuweisen ist eine arbeit für sich die
ins gebiet der religion psychologie
religionsgeschichte und philosophie
hineingehört aus diesen quellen kommend
lebt frömmigkeit längst ihr leben für
sich
aus diesem schon deutlich auf die
späteren werke ottos weisenden ansinnen
wird deutlich worin bereits jetzt die
ernte besonders seiner goethe deutung
besteht er zeichnet den weimarer dichter
insbesondere im blick auf morphologie
und farbenlehre als einen herausragenden
virtuosen eben jener besonderen quelle
der erkenntnis die ihnen gerade nicht
durch spekulation zu einer
teleologischen welt frömmigkeit führt
sondern umgekehrt ihn in theologischer
weltdeutung erst nachträglich wieder
erkennen lässt was er zuvor auf ganz
eigenem intuitiven wege der inspiration
geschaut hat
erst später findet otto begriffe für
dieses ahnden und domino so erleben
einstweilen ist es hier noch eine spur
die er vor zeichnet und bereits jetzt
mit dem begriff des mysteriums wie eben
schon erwähnt zusammenfasst gemeint ist
ein glutkern der religion der allein auf
dem weg der andacht zu finden sei er
schreibt frömmigkeit sucht tiefe in den
dingen
sie streckt sich nach einem im letzten
grunde verborgenen und unverstandenen
und geheimnisvollen spekulative
religionsphilosophie ist.foto
demgegenüber einen dienender rahmen die
er schreibt eine begriffliche rationale
annäherungs bewegung an das eigentliche
dem es aber letztlich und das ist die
kritik nach gängig ist
es ist kaum bekannt dass auf die
naturalismus arbeiten in völliger
zusammenbruch ottos folgte nicht nur
beruflich das war auch eine katastrophe
sondern auch psychisch und inhaltlich
theologisch stürzte otto hier in eine
tiefe krise die in fast zwei jahre
arbeitsunfähig machte besonders der
briefwechsel mit roche ist hier sehr
eindrucksvoll
erst die spur zu fries besonders aber
auch die entdeckung der
religionsgeschichte auf spektakulären
reisen um die ganze welt und in
übersetzungen in die sadt indischer
texte aus dem sanskrit findet otto dann
die wende und eine völlig neue spur
die dann in das hauptwerk mündet das den
fast gescheiterten blitzartig
weltberühmt machte zu diesem buch komme
ich jetzt das mit autos buch das heilige
ein schauer der erleuchtung und
befreiung durch deutsche evangelische
christen gegangen sei und sie aus um
strickenden und nieder ziehenden
verbindungen heraus geführt habe wie
hana in einer rezension vermeldete hing
sicherlich in den zeitbedingten
krisenbewusstsein zusammen was besonders
jene leser eindrücklich in worte fassten
die das buch im trommelfeuer des ersten
weltkriegs larsen was paul tillich
seinem freund emanuel hirsch 1918 aus
dem schützengraben über sein geradezu
ekstatisches lektüre erlebnis des
heiligen schrieb und was die zeitgleiche
ort zur rezension des felt predigers
ehlert im kern ausmacht liegt an diesem
punkt auf einer linie wie mir scheint
man sah insbesondere das erbeben des
deutschen idealismus in den großen
krisen des frühen zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts zusammenbrechen und erlebte
autos buch als epochalen
befreiungsschlag gegenüber dem ad
absurdum geführten spekulativen
optimismus des neunzehnten jahrhunderts
in das heilige macht otto mit der
unterscheidung von rational und
irrational explizit was nun als grundzug
seines zeitalters gelten kann
er traf mit seiner hinwendung zur
religionsgeschichte und dem versuch den
uhr phänomenen religiösen lebens auf den
grund zu gehen den nerv einer
fundamentalen krise religiöser
ausdrucksformen die pointe bestand dabei
darin das zitat immer inadäquate der
ausdrucksmittel der religion nicht an
einer bestimmten epoche oder einem
bestimmten theologischen stil
festzumachen sondern das zitat
vorantreibende die ruhende in der
vorstellungs produktion der religion als
notwendiges und zeitloses uhr problem
der religionsgeschichte überhaupt
anzunehmen
die berühmte annäherung an die
grundmotive religiösen erlebens in der
kontrast harmonie das mysterium tremaine
dumm etwas finanz als den
unmittelbarsten spiegelungen der
intuition für das ganz andere und
irrationalen ominöse steuert letztlich
auf die einsicht zu dass von jenem
moment und fluchtpunkt aller frömmigkeit
letztlich nicht angemessen zu reden sei
die formen und formellen der
religionsgeschichte sind demnach
thematisierung und idei gramme für
schlechterdings unfassliche damit rücken
besonders jene gestalten der
geistesgeschichte in den mittelpunkt des
interesses bei denen diese grenze der
angemessenen darstellung explizit
thematisiert wird
die beispiele reichen von dunklen hohen
mysterien über propheten und religiöse
lichtgestalten wie hier computer bis hin
zu abstrakten mystikern und philosophen
bei ihnen allen geht es um die gleiche
unmögliche möglichkeit nämlich
angemessen vom eigentlichen des erlebens
von
natur gefühl und der domino so scheu als
das ur moments aller religionen zu reden
und dabei zugleich die unausweichliche
unangemessenheit ihrer rede mit zu
denken oder mit zu integrieren da ihr
gegenstand eben nicht erfahrbar und
erfassbar sondern letztlich ein im
gefühl erahnt das geheimnis ist otto
charakterisierte später das anliegen
seines werkes mit folgenden worten jetzt
kommt ein sehr langes zitat der
untertitel unserer schrift über das
heilige war über das irrationale in der
idee des göttlichen aber die absicht der
schrift war gerade eine rationale
gewesen nämlich die den irrationalen
momenten in der gottes idee zwar recht
wieder zu geben und sie ins licht zu
stellen
aber sie eben ins licht zu stellen das
heißt sie nicht in einen allgemeinen
nebel des irrationalen zu versetzen in
dem wie hegel sagt alle kühl grau sind
sondern sie in strenger gefühls analyse
und durch video grammatische
symbolisierung nach möglichkeit zu
unterscheiden zu charakterisieren und so
dass faire des rationalen anzunähern und
zugleich zu zeigen dass sie der rand
sind an klaren rationalen momenten die
ebenso zum gehalte der gottes idee
gehören denn dies ist eben der
sachverhalt das was über alle vernunft
ist und vor dem name und begriff
umkehren
das ist doch selber zugleich grund und
quell aller vernunft aller theoretischen
wie praktischen vernunft
es ist wie paul tillich es treffend
genannt hat grund und abgrund zugleich
ohne diese rationalen momente wäre das
nun nicht gott wäre der domino sie nicht
wert der nominale wert nicht dass
sanctum und ganz gewiss nicht das
heilige des christlichen glaubens an
dieser tatsache willen es christlicher
glaube aufs innigste interessiert an
einer welt die unter ideen der ratio
zumal unter ideen von zweck und
zweckmäßiger leitungen und gestaltung
begriffen und gedeutet werden kann
zitat ende
keineswegs ist otto also ein pauschaler
gegner rationaler und spekulativer rede
vom göttlichen ganz im gegenteil
allerdings versieht er scheinbar alles
rationale der religion mit einem
grundlegenden vorbehalt der
unangemessenheit gegenüber den gemeinden
in zahlreichen beispielen führt er vor
wie die dunkle unmittelbare intuition
des nominalen durch religions-
philosophische und dogmatische
operationen allzu leicht verkappt und
verbrämt und damit letztlich überlagert
werden kann grundsätzlich neigt otto
dazu und das ist sicherlich auch das
neue und aufsägen aufsehenerregende an
seinem entwurf den rohren und archaisch
anmutenden ausdrucksformen der
religionsgeschichte eine gewissermaßen
größere nähe oder eine größere
adäquatheit gegenüber den sie
hervorbringen den intuitionen zu
unterstellen und zieht damit einen
schlussstrich unter jenen maßgeblich
auch durch das neunzehnte jahrhundert
befeuerten geschichts optimismus einer
religiösen aufstiegs entwicklung von den
primitiv animistischen anfängen bis hin
zur vollkommenen absoluten religion des
geistes der rationalen arbeit
gottesbegriff steht die unmittelbare
intuition als eigenständige und
vorausgehende quelle gegenüber bis hin
zu dem gedanken das zitat spekulationen
über das absolute überschattet sein von
motive des von motiven des rein
nominalen ganz anderen dem anja tv die
als solche von der spekulation über
absolutheit noch ganz unabhängig sind
und die auch da schon wirksam sind wo
die ideen der absolutheit noch nicht
gefasst sind
unter den prominentesten beispielen
jener religiösen genies die das ganz
andere unabhängig und von spekulativen
und dogmatischen begriffen unabhängig
von spekulativen und dogmatischen
begriffen zu erfassen vermögen steht
schließlich auch hier gute im
mittelpunkt der so otto die motive
seiner eigenen virtuosen schau des
dämonischen nicht mit dem idealistischen
gottesbegriff seinerzeit und erst recht
nicht mit dem dogmatischen lehren des
christentums hat zusammenbringen können
bevor ich auf diese durchaus originelle
deutung goethes zurück komme möchte ich
aber kurz noch auf eben jenes werk
hinweisen dass mir hinsichtlich der
frage nach autos stellung zu idealismus
nochmal etwas aufschlussreicher zu sein
scheint in dem werk west-östliche mystik
von 1926 vertieft otto ein problem das
in das heilige er ein nebengleis
darstellt nämlich die frage nach der
eigentlichen beziehung des unmittelbaren
erlebens zu den großen spekulativen
traditionen der religionsgeschichte der
süffisante satz in das heilige
demzufolge zitat gerade die mystik
meistens sehr beredt gewesen sei obwohl
sie ihrem eigenen anspruch nach doch
eigentlich nur im schweigen bestehen
hätte müssen legt diese spur von otto
ist besonders die mystik ein zentraler
ort der beziehung und verflechtung
rationaler und irrationaler momente
ausgerechnet mystisches erleben drängt
nach ottos beobachtung besonders stark
und zuweilen schrill in formen und
begriffliche kapriolen bis hin zu
spekulativen schleifen die zum
eigentlichen erleben selbst in einen
eigens eigentümlichen kontrast stehen
mit meister eckhart und ankara hat otto
nun zwei große protagonisten eben solch
spekulativer mystic vor augen die aus
völlig unterschiedlichen welten kommen
anhand eines umfassenden mehrere hundert
seiten umfassenden vergleich ihres
denkens liegt otto in seinem buch das
auch in amerika gehaltenen vorlesungen
zurückgeht
eine damals bahnbrechende studie zum
wesen mystischen denkens vor und liefert
darüber hinaus eine bemerkenswerte
arbeit zu den religions- philosophischen
kontaktstellen indischer und
europäischer religionsgeschichte für die
fragestellung dieser tagung ist das
dicke und akribisch religions-
philosophische buch in gewisser weise
folgender weise interessant nämlich weil
otto es nicht nur bei einem vergleich
eckarts und ankaras und der
aufschlüsselung unterschiedlicher
mystischer wege wie er es nennt bewenden
lässt sondern weil er auch direkte
bezüge zu deren neuzeitlichen erbe und
insbesondere zu vertretern des des
deutschen idealismus zieht die
grundthese ist zunächst dass eckert und
ankara gar keine mystiker im
landläufigen sinne also keine
meditierenden asketen oder so seien
sondern dass die eigentliche heilslehre
beider im spekulativen denken denken und
in wegen der erkenntnis verborgen liegen
in beiden werden damit auf kuriose weise
zitat verkünder eines letztlich
schlechthin irrationalen unfasslich
formal zu schärfsten theoretikern zu
strengsten scholastika die
einzelanalysen sind wirklich hoch
komplex und sehr vielschichtig und
können unmöglich jetzt wiedergegeben
werden daher versuche ich die pointe
zusammenzufassen
auf dieses auto meines erachtens ankommt
demnach erwägen eckhardt und ankara
zunächst den eindruck als sei das ziel
und der fluchtpunkt ihrer lehre
bezüglich des ipss um es gottes
erkenntnis und des heils auf dem wege
ihrer wissenschaftlich spekulativen
operationen wirklich und tatsächlich zu
erreichen
tatsächlich führt aber genau die ist
nach ottos auffassung in die irre und
man sieht sich vor lauter zirkeln und
denke schon schließlich in einen wald in
dem man in einen wald versetzte den man
vor lauter bäumen nicht sieht wie er
sagt nur in seltenen durchbrüchen durch
die wie er schreibt trockene hülse der
spekulation otto benennt sie hier auch
schon mit goethes ab es wird
demgegenüber deutlich dass der
eigentliche quellgrund ihrer
spekulativen systeme jenseits der
spekulation und begriffe liegt nämlich
in einem prinzipien intuit tus mystikers
wie otto es nennt der dann jedoch wieder
unmittelbar in ihrer dialektik
verschleiert werde in zahlreichen
beispielen arbeitet otto diese
leerstellen des intuitives heraus in
denen die begriffe verstummen und eine
die ganze spekulation tragende und
zugleich auf lebende gefühls dimension
hindurch schimmert in ihr sieht otto das
eigentlich mystische erkennt aber an
dass die spekulative hülle
im fall jener west-östlichen spur kein
überflüssiges beiwerk sondern ein
wesentlicher und sogar unabdingbarer
bestandteil der annäherung an das
intuitiv geschaut und erlebte mysterium
ist im dritten hauptteil des buches
versucht otto nun parallelen der neueren
geistesgeschichte auszumachen
die in jener mythischen traditionslinie
stehen und landet prompt im deutschen
idealismus bei hegel schelling schlegel
schopenhauer besonders aber beim späten
fichte der wie gesagt schon in der reden
edition für otto wichtig waren
sicherlich zu seinen lieblingen im
deutschen idealismus zählt fichte stellt
er ausführlich da geradezu sie optisch
mit eckart und indischen lehrern im
vergleich das läuft sogar regelrecht
auch philologische tabellen hinaus er
spricht von einer geradezu von einer
renaissance e cards bei fichte in langen
und detaillierten vergleich ungen aller
argumentation schritte zeichnete fichte
fichtes anweisungen zum seligen leben
nach
das kann ich jetzt nicht nach zeichen
dass auch das ist sehr komplex wird
immer wieder durch kommentiert worauf
läuft es raus in dem motto bei fichte
lebens und science begriff ineinander
fallen sei fichtes ontologie und jetzt
kommt ein zitat wie eckart ontologie
maske eines irrationalen dass keine
science lehre ausschöpft wk3 wie ihn
eine innere nötigung ja sagt zur science
spekulation die aus intuitiv
irrationalem antrieb heraus notwendiger
teil und ausdrucksformen des schlechten
omen ist indessen evidenz otto de ponte
des begriffs der seligkeit bei fichte
erblickt fichte schreibt selbst und
dieses zitat hebt auto besonders hervor
die seligkeit ist der reflexion
unzugänglich der begriff kann die
seligkeit nur negativ ausdrücken und so
auch unsere beschreibung die nur
inbegriffen einhergeht worin aber die
seligkeit selbst positiv bestehe lässt
sich nicht beschreiben sondern nur
unmittelbar fühlen so fichte bei lotto
entscheidend für die fragestellung nach
ottos idealismus deutung scheint mir
besonders die idee der inneren
notwendigkeit des spekulativen im modus
der mystik zu sein
entgegen den anti idealistischen kräften
des frühen zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
betreibt otto ausdrücklich an dieser
stelle möglicherweise ein projekt der
reintegration des spekulativen in das
wesen der religion nämlich als dessen
ureigener mystischer drang der redaktion
ahlen annäherung
man könnte das gemeinte vielleicht als
moment der grenz abschreibung bezeichnen
den otto tief im wesen der religion und
ihren rabbi rationalen gründen verankert
sieht und damit auch in der großen
epoche des neunzehnten jahrhunderts als
religiöses grundbedürfnis wiedererkennt
die letztlich ganz einfacher grund
maxime würde demnach lauten spekulative
religionsphilosophie von den ältesten
mystikern bis zur fichte hegel und co
beschreibt das eigentliche der religion
in klaren und vollendeten begriffen aber
es ist nicht die erkenntnis quelle
dieses eigentlichen das nicht reduziert
war sondern nur erlebbar ist aus eben
jener innere nötigung heraus und dann
zur spekulation drängt die latente
gefahr ihnen ist ganz eigenen mystischen
weges besteht für otto in geschichte und
gegenwart letztlich darin dass jene
eigentlichen intuitiven quell gründe
allzu leicht hinter den klaren
kristallen der ontologie verschwimmen
und schließlich sogar ganz vergessen
werden können
zugunsten einer fatalen
verselbstständigung der spekulativen
elemente die dann letztlich religiös
austrocknen
es bleibt also eine eindeutige
uneindeutigkeit und ambivalenz in ottos
verhältnis dazu ich komme zur führt ins
auto und goethe wie bereits angedeutet
möchte ich vorschlagen den roten faden
wenn es denn überhaupt gibt in dieser
beschriebenen spurensuche die auch
wirklich nur eine versuchte spurensuche
ist in aller kürze an der goethe deutung
autos etwas mehr fest zu binden und zu
konkretisieren
hierfür spricht nicht nur das goethe wie
bereits erwähnt besonders auch in den
genannten werken autos immer wieder
direkt und indirekt präsent ist
entscheidend ist vielmehr dass ottos bei
goethe gewonnene begriffe und anregungen
in besonderer weise gerade an jene
kontaktstellen heftet die sich zwischen
rationalen und irrationalen elementen
der religionen befinden
die mir für die fragestellung auch der
bedeutung des idealistischen erbes bei
otto maßgeblich zu sein scheint
gerade zu plakativ zeigt sich dies in
der unter otto freundin legendären
schlussbemerkung über gefühl in jenem an
ottos letzten aufsatzband von 1932
unscheinbar angeklebten und überaus
tiefsinnigen kurz aufsatz zur theorie
der religiösen intuition
dort schlägt otto für das dreibändige
herzstück seines gesamtwerks also das
heilige und die beiden dicken aufsatz
bände ein gesamt motto vor was er wenig
überraschend erneut goethe entnimmt und
dass eben jene grundproblematik der
religion zwischen gefühl und vernunft
irrationalen und rationalen elementen
auf den punkt bringen soll
es handelt sich um einen unscheinbaren
satz aus goethes besprechung von
stiegenroth psychologie zur erklärung
der seelen erscheinen und er lautet um
denselben punkt streiten sich die
schüler einer gefühls und vernunft
religion wenn die letzteren nicht
eingestehen wollen dass die religion vom
gefühl anfalle anfange so wollen die
ersten nicht zugeben dass sie sich zur
vernünftigkeit ausbilden müsse diesen
selben punkt an denen sich begriff und
intuition anziehen und zugleich abstoßen
bestimmt otto hier als ein intuitives
als ein zitat intuitives zugleich mit
stärksten wertungen durchdrungene sfor
begriffliches erfassen da das nach ottos
auffassung den begriff des asyl bei
goethe weitgehend entspricht jene
intuition drängt in die vernünftigkeit
wird von dort aber ebenso in die quellen
des gefühls zurückgewiesen
es geht otto dabei bekanntlich um nicht
weniger als um eine eigene erkenntnis
kategorie sui generis die wieder
emotionen noch reflexion sondern
vielmehr ein unmittelbares werten
erkennen und deuten eigener art ist das
haben wir eben schon viel besser gehört
goethe ist zu jene theorie religiöser
intuition nicht deshalb wichtig weil
otto sie bei ihm als theorie gefunden
hätte das war natürlich nicht der fall
hier ist schleiermacher friesland die
erste adresse sondern weil er das damit
gemeinte bei goethe in überaus genialer
und anschaulicher weise gelebt und
unmittelbar zum ausdruck gebracht sah
und vor allem in origineller weise
ausgedruckten ausgedrückt sei das beste
beispiel ist hierfür goethes begriff des
dämonischen der in das heilige eine
zentrale rolle spielt und auch zum motto
von das heilige geführt hat sie wissen
dass dem heiligen das zitat aus der
zweiten teil des faust voran steht das
schau dann ist der menschheit beste
style und so weiter also diese szene aus
der dunklen galerie wo ist da um die
mutter geht also sehr sehr dämonische
ganz dunkle kapitel auch bei goethe dem
dämonischen bei goethe erblickt otto
alle grundmotive seiner momente des
nominalen wieder nimmt aber dann zur
kenntnis dass diese bei goethe
schlechterdings dunkel bleiben und sich
jeder schema ti sierung entziehen
gerade der heide goethe wie otto betont
findet das domino sie eben gerade
jenseits verfasster religionsformen und
markiert damit die tiefste nur gründe
des nominalen überhaupt laut otto
gelingt es goethe dabei eben gerade
nicht seinen auch aus dem umfeld des
idealismus geprägten reinen
gottesbegriff mit jener dunklen
intuition des dämonischen
zusammenzubringen und deutet damit auf
jenen graben den otto schon in der
mystik als kernproblem ausmachte nämlich
von den rohen urformen der intuition ist
der spekulative gottesbegriff des
idealismus eigentümlich entfernt
entscheidend sind für ihn als quelle die
gespräche mit eckermann dichtung und
wahrheit und viele andere quellen die
otto hier sehr geschickt miteinander
verzahnt das dämonische wie otto ist
versteht im anschluss an goethe ist also
geradezu ein rohes rebellisches moment
dass sich jeder form von schema ti
sierung auch insbesondere in der
religion verweigert
goethe ist für otto damit geradezu die
verkörperung des intuitiven erkennens
vor jeder ausformung und dass es gerade
im goethe der divina torischen natur wie
otto sagt nicht gelangen seine dunklen
apa süß seine intuition für das
dämonische mit dem gottesbegriff oder
gar mit dem christentum zu verbinden
gibt otto zu denken und bestärkt ihn
letztlich in seiner vorsicht
hinsichtlich vernunft basierter gottes
begrifflichkeit was ein ominöse
schäumend markiert damit eine
unüberwindbare thematisierung grenze und
religionsgeschichtlichen geschichte wäre
die machen eine große erzählung davon
hinzu kommt ein ganz äußerlicher grund
für den stellenwert goethes den
eingehender zu untersuchen sicher
spannend wäre nämlich die krisenstimmung
nach dem ersten weltkrieg fiel mit einer
bemerkenswerten goethe renaissance im
protestantismus zusammen die besonders
auch otto nahe stehende persönlichkeiten
wie träsch und ganz besonders adolf von
harnack ergriff man könnte hier auch
noch dilthey simmel kassierer und viele
andere erwähnen die also brot goethe
lesende protagonisten jederzeit waren
der in diesem umfeld latente zug zu
einem von der dogmengeschichte befreiten
und aus den klammern der philosophie
gelösten protestantismus der
innerlichkeit und intuitiven
ergriffenheit fand ebenso wie otto
besonders im späten gute inspiration und
inspirierendes material holz hat dazu
einen sehr umfassenden aufsatz zum
goethe dienst als gottesdienst
geschrieben der aufschlussreich wenn
diese diese diese linie dieser zeit ist
parallel dazu ist auch ein ist eine
besonders für münchner als lokalkolorit
interessantes phänomen in der kunst das
genau in dieser zeit hier das um
darstellbare bei kandinsky malewitsch
und so weiter entdeckt wird und sich
auch mit dem begriff der mystic
auseinandersetzt schwarze quadrat auf
weißem grund und so weiter ist also ein
interessanter seiten kapitel genau in
dieser phase
ich versuche kurz zusammenzufassen
welche punkte sich aus den chorischen
durchgang ergaben auto aktualisiert
unter den bedingungen der moderne ein
altes drama der theologie das legendäre
den alten thomas von aquin schon sein
werk als stroh bezeichnen liegt die
frage nach der angemessenheit
theologischer reflexion gegenüber den
quellen religiöser intuition oder weiß
dabei auf den seltsamen drang und das
bedürfnis nach spekulativen elementen
hin die er besonders in der mystik und
in den irrationalen durchbruch stellen
an der grenze des rationalen ringen
sieht im blick auf die fragestellung
dieser tagung wurde denke ich deutlich
dass otto allen anti idealistischen
vereinnahmung seiner zeit und besonders
auch seiner wirkungsgeschichte in der
religionswissenschaft zum trotzdem ist
idealistischen erbe deutlich verbunden
war gegen alles existenzialistische
kommunistische und materialistische hat
er sich immer verweigert seine
zurückhaltung gegenüber den spekulativen
und metaphysischen tendenzen der
theologie ist weder unkenntnis noch
geringschätzung sondern viel mehr
vorsicht name hinsichtlich der
verselbstständigung tendenzen
religionsphilosophie spekulativer
operationen gegenüber ihrem irrationalen
grund das entscheidende
zugleich kann man autos werk im
besonderen blick auf sein die wie zieles
mystik verständnis auch als projekt zur
reintegration des spekulativen in das
wesen der religion auffassen und zwar in
dem sinne dass die spekulation in seinem
fall am beispiel eckarts bis fichtes
ausgeführt nicht als dem eigentlich
religiösen erleben fremde und sekundäre
operationen sondern als unmittelbar aus
der religiösen intuition hervorgehen
dass gleichsam in die grenzen des
rationalen abschreiten das element
begriffen wird man könnte hier
vielleicht auch eine bleibende anregung
sehen der sich die mit idealistischen
erbe hantieren der theologie auszusetzen
hat
nämlich das faustische unkontrollierbare
das dunkel dämonische und das
unauslöschbare ab asyl als etwas dem
eigenen wesen wesentliches zu begreifen
ganz in diesem sinne hat und jetzt kommt
er da tatsächlich noch mal zu wort
emanuel hirsch einmal etwas über paul
althaus gesagt nämlich eher paul althaus
wird in seiner theologie dem geheimnis
der unserem verstand sich entziehen denn
erkennbarkeit der gottheit nicht so
gerecht wie ich es möchte
er weiß mir zuviel von gottes wesen und
art dies beruht darauf dass er nicht wie
ich durch das verheerende feuer der
kritik johann gottlieb fichte am
überlieferten gottesbegriff gegangen ist
ich könnte mir vorstellen dass diesem
feurigen erbe des idealismus auch otto
etwas abgewinnen könnte aber nicht ohne
darauf hinzuweisen dass es an dieser
stelle auch mystische durchbruch stellen
bei fichte gibt zumindest meint er die
zu erkennen die dann von einem ganz
anderen feuer erzählen